Hi how are you first time nominee you
ready to go yeah yeah yeah you said on
the nomination day like this would be
Redemptive for you to be nominated what
do you mean
you know I think that was when I was in
my phase of
my
30-year phase of wanting external
validation and I think um
[Music]
yeah
I think I've learned a lot about
myself between that time and this time
even in the last three days just leading
into
Grammy weekend you know like
I don't know I don't know how to
describe it but
it it was more I don't know if you know
I didn't I didn't take the category
Ozzie did it's like an honor to be in
the category with with Ozzie especially
I I did this movie called The Dirt where
we kind of honored Ozzy in this movie
and um
yeah it was really it's it was more
cathartic and more
um
[Music]
I learned a bigger lesson in the
45-minute car ride that I had on the way
here than I think I've learned in 30
years and like that was
it's the beginning of my uh
my journey of self-worth come on baby
and we're learning that yeah we're
learning that yeah yeah and
the nomination
at what started them no you know you
know what told me I was enough was all
the texts from all my friends and and
you know what all my the whole game
coming in my house before I left
and my daughter being so uh present and
and she has she is she's she's a gem man
I'm a lot I'm a lucky father like uh
that like
dude
a family I come from a life of of no
family and I've been gifted through
music and through through this movement
like uh
a new family and I I yeah I I don't know
what I don't know what could ever
validate that I think once I learned
that lesson
the all those accolades that I that
I desired so much then they will come
when somebody needed to hear that though
because there's somebody out there
that's lean I Thought Machine Gun Kelly
had such a Charmed Life and to know that
he's struggling with some of the things
I struggle with and battling to become
that person who knows their worth
somebody need to hear that oh that
nomination is for them I mean that
category already I came in as a hip-hop
artist and I was nominated for best rock
album like already the barriers were
broken on what
what my limits were already supposed to
be set at and I broke through that and I
mean
I'll never forget the day I made my
guitar pink and I decided to come out
and play it and uh
I don't know man I'm I'm I'm I'm very
I'm very happy and I'm very grateful and
I did I'm here for the kids who are lost
on the airport because they don't know
what
who don't know what their life is or
what it's going to be because I'm
supposedly this person that
people think knows what
thinks I have a grip on my life and I
and I don't and I'm just kind of at the
whim of the waves of the universe and
the waves are pushing me this way and
it's inspiring me to
I don't know here's to the journey
because the journey is worth taking it
and by the way your lady looks real good
tonight she's oh she's the best she's
she's the most the most beautiful she's
Godly yeah absolutely absolutely
what is what is this
what's it made out of Angel skin
[Music]